with probability equal to 1/2.
There's no special name
for this operation, at least not that I'm aware of.
It's just an example, but you could imagine performing
this operation on a bit.
Just like deterministic operations, probabilistic operations can
be represented by matrices and their actions on probabilistic states
are given by matrix-vector multiplication just like before.
This time, it's not necessarily the case that the matrices have exactly one, one in each column and zeros otherwise.
Probabilistic operations are
more generally represented by stochastic matrices.
These are matrices whose entries are all
non-negative real numbers and where the entries in
each column sum to one.
That's equivalent to saying
that stochastic matrices are matrices where every column
forms a probability vector.
That makes sense when you think about
the action of a matrix on a standard basis vector.
You consider whatever
classical state you wish and you imagine dropping that state into the top of the matrix in whatever column corresponds
to that classical state,
and that column tells you what
the probabilistic state is that comes out as a probability vector.
The probabilistic operation
in our example, for instance, is described by this matrix right here.
If we perform this operation
on the classical state zero, then the probabilistic state we get is given by the first column,
which is, again, the classical state zero or equivalently, the probabilistic
state where zero occurs with probability one.
If instead, we perform this operation on the classical state one, then we effectively just randomize the bit and correspondingly, we get
this probability vector here
where the probability for
each of the possible states is equal to 1/2.
In general, if we perform this operation on any probabilistic state, then the effect is essentially
just a weighted average between the two columns
because that's how a matrix-vector
multiplication works.
It's linear, so we just average the two
possible outcomes accordingly.
When we think about probabilistic
operations in this way, it's natural to think about
them as potentially introducing or injecting randomness.
We can just read the columns one by one and we can see the randomness
that they introduce for each possible classical state.
You can also think about
probabilistic operations in a slightly different way, which is that they're random choices of deterministic operations.
For instance, in our example, we can think about this operation as being equivalent to
flipping a fair coin
and either performing the
constant zero function or the identity function
each with probability 1/2,
and you can see that reflected
right here by this equation.
That's always possible for
any probabilistic operation, and it's pretty intuitive.
If you made random choices
as part of some process, you could always imagine making those random choices in advance
and then hard coding those
choices into some collection of deterministic operations.
It's sometimes quite helpful to think about probabilistic
operations in this way, and we'll see an example
of this down the road in a couple of lessons.
The last thing to say
about classical information for this lesson concerns composing
probabilistic operations, which just means performing
one after the other.
Let's suppose that we
have some system named X and M1 through Mn are stochastic matrices representing probabilistic
operations on X.
Imagine first that we have
a probability vector v, which represents a probabilistic
state of X at some moment, and then we first apply
the first probabilistic operation to X, which is represented by the matrix M1, and then we apply the second
probabilistic operation,
which is represented by M2.
If we do that, then the
probability vector we get after applying just the first
operation is M1 times v,
and then when we apply
the second operation, the resulting probability vector is M2 multiplied to whatever vector we obtained
after applying M1. So it looks like this.
Now, matrix multiplication
is an associative operation, which means that it doesn't matter where we put these parentheses.
So we could just as easily
put the parentheses like this.
That's very simple, but it's also interesting because it reveals that we
can think about the operation where we first apply M1
and then we apply M2
as a single operation.
In other words, the
probabilistic operation we get by composing the first and
second probabilistic operation is represented by the
matrix product, M2 times M1,
and that's the same operation regardless of what probabilistic
state we started with.
We don't need to know anything about the probability vector v to think about or to describe
this composed operation.
Notice that the order
here is M2 on the left and M1 on the right, which is because the
matrix on the right, M1,
is the one that gets
multiplied to the vector v, whereas M2 gets multiplied
to whatever vector we get after multiplying by M1.